The Covid-19 crisis created
a serious recession worldwide
and put the European economy on its knees.
Now we need €750 billion
to rebuild our Union,
a new EU that is sustainable,
green, socially inclusive,
digital and doesn't leave
anyone behind.
And there are solutions to find
that kind of money,
without making most citizens pay.
Member States leaders
need to take action!
Today, millions of jobs are at risk
and the risk is greater than ever
that we lose sight of the climate emergency.
The risk is high that, like after the 2008 crisis,
billions will be handed to banks
while the costs of the crisis will be paid by the citizens
through austerity measures.
We're not going to let that happen.
Europe needs more money for its citizens,
now more than ever,
to save jobs,
to save SMEs,
to improve our healthcare system,
to insulate houses, to invest in trains
and bike lanes,
in cleaner energy and farming,
which can create millions of green jobs,
by stimulating the flow of revenues to the EU.
Own resources are basically money that go
into the European Union budget
without adding further pressure either
on people or on national budgets,
but rather by pursuing policies
that no Member State could efficiently
implement on its own,
such as the protection of the environment
and the preservation
of a fair and social Europe.
The key issue is where do we find that money?
We have proposed several options,
have the largest companies in the EU contribute
and pay their fair share of taxes.
Right now, multinational companies
harboring their gains in fiscal havens
don't pay any tax on the profit they make.
The average corporate tax rate in Europe
has fallen by half over the last 40 years.
With a solid corporate tax rate agreed
at EU level, we could stop the race to the bottom
and generate the resources necessary
to face common European challenges.
We have big digital companies like Google and Amazon
which benefit from loopholes.
But sometimes they pay no taxes at all in Europe.
So, if an agreement is not reached
at the international level,
Europe should take the lead.
If we tax big digital companies,
we will have enough money
to finance entirely
the Next Generation EU.
If we tax the digital companies,
we could supplement the budget
of our union
and make our tax system fairer.
We need to reduce the plague
of tax evasion and tax fraud
that takes money from the citizens.
But we also need to finally start
taxing financial transactions.
Big financial players need to pay
their fair share to society.
When all of us buy a phone,
we pay a VAT of minimum 15 %.
Even for basic necessities like food,
even the most vulnerable pay a minimum of 5.5 %.
Why is it that buying stocks
on financial markets is taxed at 0.0 %?
We call on all Member States to finally create a solid
financial transaction tax.
It will put a stop to the high frequency trading
bets that lead to
massive gains for the financial sector,
while threatening our economic stability.
We ask for a Single Market Levy.
See it as a...subscription.
The big companies are the ones
that benefit from us building
the single market.
And if they use it, they have to pay for it.
That is only fair.
Such a levy, to be proportionally modulated
according to companies'
turnover would generate billions to be spent on
our common priorities.
We should use this momentum
to make our economies stronger,
more social and more sustainable.
We need money to make the Green Deal succeed,
to contribute to creating millions of green jobs
in all our countries, while preserving
a habitable planet.
We also need to have the polluters pay!
We need measures like a plastic tax
to draw auction revenues of
the EU Emission Trading Scheme
and a Carbon Border Adjustment Mechanism.
To avoid an outburst of unemployment
and poverty and to win the climate battle
the Socialists and Democrats
have several concrete solutions on the table.
Now, we need the political will of all
European governments
if we want these proposals to move forward.
It's now or never. We're now defining
the budget for the next seven years.
We cannot miss this opportunity.
Let’s work together!
We can make our Union socially fairer and greener!
We call on European leaders to agree to our proposals.
For Europe's future, for a better future!